[Music]
foreign
welcome back
so I like to start my sequence on
differential equations and dynamical
systems with a really really simple
example of how we might model some
system of Interest using matrices and
vectors so we're going to be you know
instead of giving you a bunch of kind of
boring lectures on what's a matrix
what's a vector you know linear algebra
I'm just going to start using them and
showing you how they can be useful for
modeling systems that change in time so
this lecture I'm going to kind of show
you how to model a weather system as a
you know kind of Matrix system of
equations and then once I do that I'm
going to code it up in Python in this
jupyter notebook and also in
in Matlab and so you know on this
YouTube video there will be chapters and
so if you want python go to the you know
python code part if you want Matlab go
to the Matlab code part I'm just going
to probably have them both in this video
so I'm going to start off with kind of
pencil and paper stuff and then later
we're going to
um
do some coding
so the example I want to start with is a
really really simple weather model okay
so this is my my weather model
um so weather is a big deal in Seattle
and we know that there are okay so this
is kind of a glib oversimplification
this is kind of a cutesy lecture but you
know we're going to over simplify and
say that our weather can be three states
it can be cloudy
okay it can be cloudy it can be rainy
remember we're in Seattle it can be
cloudy it can be rainy and it can be
nice and I'm kind of joking because it's
actually been a beautiful summer it's
nice a lot of the time but you know we
like to we like to talk up our rain here
and so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to build a very simple probabilistic
model for how you know whatever the
weather is today will predict what the
weather is tomorrow and we're going to
model this as a sequence of you know the
weather today the weather tomorrow the
next day the next day the next day so
this is going to be a discreet
um kind of evolution in time of the
state of the current weather is it
cloudy is it rainy or is it nice and so
um you know a lot of what we're going to
see in differential equations are going
to be what we call deterministic so if I
know the state of my system now then I
will exactly know the state of my system
in the future so for example if I have a
pendulum and I know exactly Theta its
angle and Theta dot the rate of change
of that angle I can you know uniquely
and exactly specify what that pendulum
will do for all future time that's
deterministic this is what I'm going to
call an example of a probabilistic model
and so I also want to give you uh kind
of this this comfort that we can model
things probabilistically or
deterministically those are both very
important strategies and modeling okay
so let's jump in so what we're going to
do is we're going to build a probability
model for if it's cloudy today what are
the chances of it being cloudy tomorrow
or rainy tomorrow or nice tomorrow and
then the same for all of these three
states so we're just I'm just going to
make these up this is not you know from
the Weather Service or anything but
let's say if it's cloudy today then
there's a 50 chance it'll be cloudy
tomorrow so 50 that's 0.5 okay A little
squeaky and let's say that if it's
cloudy today there is a you know 25
chance of 0.25 uh chance that it'll be
nice tomorrow and a 0.25 chance a 25
chance that it's rainy tomorrow
remember probabilities have to add up to
one so 50 is 0.5 25 is 0.25 and these
all add up to one so if it's cloudy
today there's probability one that it
will be either cloudy nice or rainy
tomorrow so that's That's essential that
this you know all of the arrows going
out of cloud you have to add up to one
because that's what how probability
Works similarly rainy let's say if it's
rainy today uh there's a you know one
and two chance or a 0.5 chance 50 chance
it'll be rainy tomorrow let's say
um you know if it's rainy today then
there will be a 0.25 chance of it being
cloudy I'm going to switch pens that's
driving me crazy and similarly let's say
that there is a 0.25 or a 25 chance that
if it's rainy today it'll be nice
tomorrow again we add those up and they
add up to one so the probability of
something happening tomorrow given that
it's raining today is one and then
finally uh you know nice if I start if
today is a nice day it actually is a
nice day
um what are the chances that you know
it'll be rainy cloudy you're nice so I
like to joke you know if it's nice today
it's not going to be nice tomorrow
um class is always half full and so for
this one it's going to be a little
different I'm going to say if it's nice
today there's a 50 chance it'll be rainy
tomorrow and a 50 chance that it'll be
cloudy tomorrow okay so this is I just
made this up of course this is you know
this is nonsense but this is just you
know
um a model that you can write down so
that is kind of the cool thing about
mathematical modeling is you know you
get to build these things uh the way
that you want to describe the world so
you could do this you could measure
these transitions you know judiciously
over years and build this model uh or
you can do other things to build these
models
and so now what we're going to do is we
are essentially going to build a little
I'm going to call this a dynamical
system it kind of changes in time it's
dynamical and it's a system where
essentially
we're going to build a um
a model we're going to say that the
weather today so I'm going to say x is
the state of my system this is the
probability let's call this x is going
to have three states this is going to be
the probability the probability that
it's rainy the probability that it is
nice and the probability that it is
cloudy okay so the state of my system is
a vector of three numbers that should
add up to one the probability that it's
rainy nice or cloudy and so if I go
outside and I look up at the sky and I
see blue skies sunshine then probability
one is that it's nice so let's say x
today
is a vector
zero one zero okay it is not raining
because I'm like telling you today I
went outside and it's a beautiful day
it's not rainy it's not cloudy it's nice
so probability one it's nice today so
let's say let's call this x today
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to build a system that X tomorrow
will be there will be some probability
of if it's uh rainy nice or cloudy
tomorrow based on what the state of the
system is today okay so if it's
definitely nice today then we know that
there's a 50 chance that tomorrow it'll
be rainy or cloudy okay so we know for a
fact that X tomorrow is going to be you
know 0.50.5 we know that from this this
diagram here so I'm going to formalize
that into some math and then we're going
to program it up and see what happens as
we evolve the system forward in time
okay so what we're going to to try to
essentially write down is this
relationship that uh X tomorrow
X tomorrow
and I'm going to add better notation
later I'm doing the kind of simplest
thing I'm calling it today and tomorrow
we're going to use better notation later
tomorrow probably X tomorrow this is
again a vector the probability of it
being rainy nice or cloudy tomorrow is
going to equal some big Matrix a some
big three by three Matrix but it's going
to have all these probabilities in it
times x today
my state of the weather today and we
already know that X tomorrow again if
it's nice today if it's definitely nice
today then we know the answer I can just
read it off of this it's going to be a
0.5 chance a 50 chance that it's rainy
and cloudy tomorrow zero percent chance
that it's nice so the it'll be 0.50.5
and this a matrix this is a this is
where matrices come in so we've shown
how a vector can represent the state of
my system this a matrix is What's called
the transition probability or the the
kind of Markov transition probability of
how I can take a probability of my state
today and predict what that probability
of the state will be tomorrow so this a
matrix essentially quantifies
uh it quantifies it's a big three by
three a matrix and it tells me
what will it be uh what's the chance of
it being uh rainy tomorrow or nice
tomorrow
or cloudy tomorrow
given that it was rainy nice or cloudy
today
okay and so literally we are this is a
three by three matrix it's got nine
numbers and those nine numbers are these
transition probabilities okay so let's
let's work through this and build up
this a matrix from this model that we
wrote down okay so a uh if it was rainy
today what are the chances of it being
rainy tomorrow nice tomorrow cloudy
tomorrow so if it's rainy today
the chance of it being rainy tomorrow is
0.5 so I can write this down 0.5
the chance of it being nice tomorrow is
0.25
the chance of it being cloudy tomorrow
is also 0.25
and we can kind of check you know do our
accounting that probability has to add
up to one this column has to add up to
one because if it's definitely rainy
today something has to happen tomorrow
it has to be either rainy nice or cloudy
tomorrow so these probabilities have to
add up to one similarly I can I can
write down the second column of a it by
by looking at is it if it's nice today
what are the probabilities of being
rainy nice or cloudy tomorrow so if it's
nice today we kind of made up this this
artificial situation where it'll be 0.5
rainy tomorrow zero percent nice
tomorrow and 0.5 cloudy tomorrow we were
being pessimistic
um and similarly if it's cloudy today
then there's a 0.5 chance of it being
cloudy tomorrow
and there's a 0.25 chance of it being
rainy tomorrow and a 0.25 chance of it
being nice tomorrow
and so this is the a Atrix that
propagates the probability of my system
forward in time I literally take this a
matrix
and I multiply it by this Vector of my
state of the system today and I get a
new Vector out which is the state of my
system tomorrow okay that that's exactly
how this works is
um you know I take the the state the
probability of my system being rainy
nice or cloudy today I multiply it by
this probability transition Matrix my
screen saver is kicking on and I get my
probabilities of being you know rainy
nice or cloudy tomorrow okay and so if I
want to you know kind of fix up my
notation a little bit I could say that
the probability
if I have a probability if I have some
uh some expected weather Distribution on
day K on the kth day
then I can get the expected weather
Distribution on the next day on the K
plus month day
on the tomorrow day by multiplying this
by a and in doing so it essentially
allows me
to write down this progression I'm going
to do this again in another color here
that if I had you know X on day one if I
if I go outside and I look up at the sky
and it's you know either a beautiful
sunny day or maybe it's a rainy day or a
cloudy day let's just say for now that
this is you know I'm going to say it's a
cloudy day
no sorry a rainy day so that's the state
when I look up today
I can now predict what's the probability
of my weather going to be tomorrow on
day two on X2 X on day two and this is
just going to be my a matrix times X1
and I can and now there's going to be
some probability it's not a definite
thing there's going to be some
probability that's not one of it being
rainy nice or cloudy
and then if I want to know what's the
probability of the weather two days from
now on on day three you know today is
day one then X3 is going to be a times x
2. it's again I take my day 2 and I
multiply it by a to get day three which
we know is a squared times X1 and so on
and so forth if I want day four it's a
times day three x three if I want day
five it's a times X4 and so on and so
forth and I can get this uh for any
number of days I like up to a big n and
so this is a differential equation model
this is a dynamical system it's not a
differential equation I'm sorry this is
a um
a discrete update equation because these
are discrete instances in time but this
is a lot like a differential equation
they're very closely related and this
essentially tells me how a vector
representing the state of my system can
propagate forward in time through
multiplication with a matrix this is a
probability Matrix so all of the columns
have to add up to one okay and so this
is a really simple uh example very
intuitive kind of warm-up example of how
you can Model A system using vectors and
matrices so we're going to code this up
in Python we're going to code this up in
Matlab I think when I learned this
um actually I think the first time I saw
this was professor John Quintanilla at
the University of North Texas and he did
this with washing machines so the you
know dormitory washing machine can
either be broken it can be working or it
can be under repair and so he also you
know exactly the same kind of system of
the probabilities and so you could you
could walk the system forward in time
okay this is our Seattle touch on it uh
Rainey Rainey nice and cloudy good
anything else I want to tell you okay so
I'm going to give a total teaser hint
down the road in a few lectures we're
going to find out that the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues of this a matrix have a
huge role in how this probability Vector
X evolves in time so does this reach a
steady state you know does it converge
to some steady state probability
distribution what is that steady state
probability distribution it turns out
the steady state probability
distribution is the eigenvector of this
a matrix corresponding to eigenvalue one
so that's something we'll come back to
in a few lectures and really understand
deeply why that's true but for now we're
just going to code this up try it out
play around with it in Python and in
Matlab okay good
okay um again you can just pick if you
want python you can pick if you want
Matlab I'm just going to jump in and
pick one myself
okay uh let's see here we are
um
good so I think I'm going to start in
um
in Matlab here and I think you can see
yeah maybe I'll just I think uh this is
big enough so in Matlab I've created
um this dot end final a script that I'm
going to kind of work out and then I'm
going to plot stuff okay so the first
thing we're going to do I'm going to
clear all close all CLC that clears all
the memory it closes all the windows and
it clears my command window down here
I'm going to Define my a matrix my kind
of a matrix here so I'm going to say a
equals and this is pretty easy in Matlab
you just Define kind of you know the
rows separated by a semicolon so the row
is 0.5 0.5 oh point
two five semicolon enter the next row is
0.250.00.25 semicolon next row 0.25 0.5
0.5 end bracket semicolon so I have
defined this a matrix okay
uh now what I'm going to do
is I am going to Define my
um
probability of X today I'm going to say
literally I'm just going to say x today
this is not going to be the best example
of coding you've ever seen there's lots
better ways of doing this using you know
arrays and indexing I'm doing kind of
like the easiest easiest way of
implementing this idea so this is not
supposed to be an amazing code lecture
I'm just showing you kind of how to do
some quick and dirty analysis so X today
is this Vector let's say one semicolon
zero semicolon one so that creates a
column Vector I'll just show you what
that looks like here if I do x equals
one semicolon zero semicolon zero that
creates a column Vector one zero zero
if I did x equals 1 space 0 space 0 that
will create a row vector
so you'll notice that putting these
semicolons here is really important in
Matlab to turn this you know to say this
is a column Vector because if I want to
multiply a times x that X better be a
column Vector that's how matrix
multiplication works is you multiply uh
you know a matrix times a column Vector
equals a column Vector this is literally
the shape of the math we're about to do
X today times a equals x tomorrow these
are column vectors so I need I need X
today to be a column vector and I'm
using these semicolons good
okay
[Music]
um
good
and now I'm literally just going to do a
really kind of cheesy uh for Loop I'm
going to say you know 4 k equals 1 to 50
maybe there's 50 days I'm going to say x
tomorrow equals a times x today and at
the end of every day tomorrow becomes
today this is like a gorilla song okay
good
um
yeah so 4K equals 1 to 50. I'm gonna
this is you know so so there'll be like
a
example on my course website you know
links below that will give you kind of
an overview of how to do for loops and
while loops and stuff in Matlab the same
thing in Python but I also do think this
is a really nice way for you to get
you know brushed up on how to do these
things is just to Live code some things
so for k equals one to 50 we're going to
literally step through 50 days okay so
50 days and we're going to say x
tomorrow equals a times x today
pretty simple x tomorrow the probability
tomorrow is a times the probability
today
and so each of these K's from 1 to 50 is
a new day and so the at the end of today
tomorrow becomes today or today becomes
tomorrow so let's say uh X today equals
x tomorrow so at the end of so so once I
set my state forward in time for the
next day today will be the state
tomorrow ah there's no good way to say
this
on day
now on day k
X today is XK and X tomorrow is XK plus
one
but on the next day K plus 1 then X
today is X K plus 1 which was the X
tomorrow from today
you'll get this you'll get the hang of
this every time I step this thing
forward on the next day I have to
reinitialize my state today with the
state that was tomorrow
yesterday
and I have to say and in Matlab
and I probably want to plot some stuff
maybe I'll just plot X tomorrow every
you know for all of these one through
fifty and I think I can save this and
run this
uh good okay so it runs super duper fast
and you can actually see all of these
outputs without putting XMR XMR XMR on
they don't look like they're the same
number so I'm going to scroll up and see
if if they ever were not okay so
for maybe I should actually say what K
is also uh K I'm going to Output K and
then I'm also going to Output X tomorrow
not putting a semicolon on this is
telling Matlab to print that quantity so
if I just say K with no semicolon it'll
print K and X tomorrow equals a times x
today it'll print a tomorrow and here
because I put a semicolon on the end of
this line 12 it's not going to print
that line
okay so on day 50 or on day 49 this is
the probability so 40 probability of it
being rainy 20 probability of it being
nice 40 of it being cloudy uh let's
scroll up to k equals one
okay so on on the first day after today
on k equals one you know my probability
tomorrow of my state is 50 uh chance of
rain 25 chance that it's nice 25 chance
that it's cloudy let's see if that
checks out if today was rainy If today
was raining then there is a 50 chance
that it's raining tomorrow and a 25
chance that it's cloudy and a 25 chance
that it's nice so that checks out
but what happens on the second date on
the k equals two day so now I take this
0.5
0.25.25 State and I multiply that by a
to get the probability on the next day
and that is uh you know point four three
seven five point one eight seven five
point three seven five zero so you know
this probability is is different
and to get the probability of the
weather on the next day I take that
state times a and that equals
um you know this probability you can see
it's starting to kind of almost converge
to 0.4.2.4 and very quickly within you
know five or six days this thing is
converged to the steady state
probability distribution to this this
steady state probability so for this
weather model with these numbers here
from any initial State actually from if
it starts raining if it starts nice if
it starts cloudy you should code that up
and try that start with a different
initial condition all of those after a
few days after 10 days are going to
converge to this steady state
probability distribution of 40 rainy 20
nice 40 cloudy those are the
probabilities and again I told you I
would um I would demonstrate this that
this is in fact uh related to the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of that a
matrix I'll just show you that because I
think that's really important for you to
see that even if you don't remember what
an eigenvalue or eigenvector is I'm
going to have a whole set of lectures on
that in a few weeks you're going to
totally understand how this works I'm
just showing you that if I type in uh
you know I let's say t comma V equals I
of a
so these diagonal not t comma V T comma
d
so the D Matrix here these diagonal
terms are the eigenvalues sorry
eigenvalues 1.25 minus 0.25 and the
corresponding eigenvectors are these
columns here on the left these Columns
of t
and
um
you'll notice that these Columns of T
don't add up to one this is a problem
because we need our probabilities to add
up to one so if I normalize these so
that each of the columns adds up to one
let's just see like so I'm going to take
the the eigenvector the First Column
corresponding to eigenvalue one so this
First Column of T and I'm going to
normalize its probability so they add up
to one
so I'm going to say
Evac 1 equals T colon comma 1. this is
literally saying like my eigen I'm
defining something called my eigenvector
1 as the First Column of t
and I'm going to normalize it so it has
probability one so I'm going to say
let's say sum of Evac one okay is that
but I think it should add up to one so
I'm just going to say Evac 1 equals Evac
1 divided by sum of e of X1
and now lo and behold this unit
probability normalized eigenvector is
exactly what my steady state
distribution was so the eigenvector of
this a matrix corresponding to
eigenvalue one once I normalize its
probability to be sensible to add up to
one this is in fact the steady state
distribution of my system as I iterate
it through so really powerful things you
can predict the future you can predict
the steady state future distribution
just by knowing this a matrix I actually
didn't even need to iterate the system
50 days into the future because if I
know what this a matrix is I can compute
the future steady state distribution
just with the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors again you might not you're
not supposed to know exactly what that
means but that's just a teaser for
what's what's coming next what I really
want to show you here is that you can
model kind of the simple system as a
probability uh you know the state of the
system as a vector and that state
evolves In Time by matrix multiplication
and you can code it up in Matlab good
okay I'm going to do the same thing in
Python now
okay so now we're going to code up this
example in Python so we are going to
take the state of the system
um today I'm going to look up at the sky
and say oh it's nice or it's Rainier
it's cloudy we're going to initialize
that state we're going to Define this a
matrix and we're going to write a code
to step through you know given what the
probability today is what's the
probability of the weather tomorrow
what's the probability of the weather
two days three days four days five days
and we're going to analyze and kind of
plot and look at that distribution okay
so I like Jupiter notebooks
um you know you can install this using
pip install or conda you need an
up-to-date python and a Jupiter notebook
and so I'm going to do a new
python notebook here we are and this is
going to be our environment where we're
going to build this example
Okay so
the first thing I'm going to do um
python is a very powerful General
language so I'm going to need to import
some environments there's a little bit
more syntax because it can do so much
more stuff so the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to import numpy this
is literally like you know the numerical
package in Python import numpy as NP uh
and I'm going to bring in some plotting
tools so I can plot some stuff so from
uh matte plot lib these are both
packages numpy and matplotlib from
matplotlib I'm going to import uh Pi
plot as plot so this is basically going
to give me these packages NP and plot
that are going to allow me to do math NP
is going to allow me to build you know
matrices and vectors and plots going to
allow me to plot stuff
okay I'm going to run that good now I'm
going to Define my a matrix and my X
Vector so a equals and unlike in Matlab
you can't just Define this thing you
know using brackets you have to Define
it as an numpy array so it equals NP dot
array
of
and now I'm just going to enter in the
elements row by row by row okay so it's
an NP array the first row is 0.5 comma
0.5 comma 0.25
semicolon the second row is 0.25 comma
0.0 comma 0.25
next row the third row the last row is
and I hope you can see this I think you
can is 0.25 comma oh 0.5 comma 0.5 and
bracket so this is essentially going to
create a numpy array an array in this
numpy you know data structure an array
structure using this numpy package that
has this row this row and then this row
okay so I'm going to run that hopefully
no error is good and if you want to
print it out just to see if you did it
you just say print a and that's my a
matrix and it is in fact exactly what I
want it to be good
okay so that's uh that's my a matrix now
I'm going to make my Vector X today and
again we're going to walk it forward
through matrix multiplication
so uh X today equals
um you can Define vectors in a simple
way just saying uh you know kind of one
comma zero comma zero so we're going to
say that it's nice today uh print X
today and confirm I actually want this
to be a vector but we'll
um
yeah maybe maybe I want this to be uh
maybe I'm going to make this an Empire
rail so I'm going to say that this is an
NP dot array
and I'm going to make this
one comma
zero comma zero because I want this to
be a column Vector right this this state
X should be a column Vector let's hope I
didn't mess it up yeah now it's a column
Vector okay so I actually need this
thing to be a column Vector for it to
make sense
and I can do matrix multiplication
really easily I could say
um
like print a I believe it's at X today
and that is going to give me a times x
today which is again a a column Vector
of the probabilities of my state
tomorrow okay good so I'm just kind of
uh for some of you this might be your
kind of first foray into uh into python
so I'm going kind of slow here
um okay so now we're going to write that
for Loop that walks through you know for
a number of days let's say 50 days uh
we're gonna step through you know from
today tomorrow okay so let's do that
and let's say
um
4K okay so it's not from K to one to
fifty it's 4K in the range uh in range
um
50. so for K and range 50 that's like 1
to 50.
okay and you have to put a colon at the
end of this to note that everything
after that is going to be in this for
Loop and it's indented by a tab so 4K
from 1 to 50.
uh what we're going to say is X tomorrow
equals a times x today
okay
and at the end of today
my state tomorrow
that the state that was tomorrow today
becomes the today's date tomorrow
okay so I'm stepping this forward and
then at the end of the day x today
becomes X tomorrow okay
and I think what I want to do is I want
to print
X tomorrow at every single step okay I'm
just gonna do this
um
good I'm pretty sure this will run so
I'm going to run it okay and it's a
little messy because it's you know
there's all these brackets here but
we'll work through it so essentially
this first piece here that is
uh at K1 the first day in the future
this is the probability
the second day in the future this is the
probability the third day in the future
this is the probability maybe I'll print
K also I'll print K and then I'll print
X tomorrow
okay good this is a little easier to
read so today on day now on Day Zero
because that's how python indexes it
starts at zero so day now Day Zero the
probability tomorrow
oops I need to re-initialize X today
notice this is uh these are all the
steady state distribution um Let me let
me re-initialize X today
okay and then I'm going to rerun this
good so if x today is this Vector
meaning it's rainy today zero percent
nice zero percent cloudy you know 100
percent rainy then
um at k equals zero the probability of
whether tomorrow is fifty percent uh
rainy 25 cloudy 25 nice so this makes
sense and then the probability another
day in the future at k equals one is
this Vector times a that gives me the
next day uh two days into the future
you take that previous Vector times a to
get this one three days in the future
you take this Vector times a to get the
next one and so on and so forth so you
can walk this probability Vector X
forward in time X on day Zero you
multiply it by a to get X at day one you
take Exit day one multiply it by a to
get exit A2 and so on and so forth and
you can see actually it's interesting
this thing is almost starting to
converge at point four point two point
four so if I scroll down a little bit
very quickly within you know five or six
days the probability has converged to
this steady state distribution where the
probability of it being rainy is forty
percent the probability of it being nice
is twenty percent the probability of it
being cloudy as forty percent
and again uh in a few lectures I'm going
to show you we're going to derive kind
of from scratch that this steady state
probability distribution is in fact the
eigenvector of this a matrix
corresponding to eigenvalue one that's a
property in fact of all of these Markov
probability transition matrices any
Matrix where its columns add up to one
which is a trans a probability
transition Matrix the probability of
transitioning from a state to Day to a
state tomorrow or from one state to
another state if it has that property of
conservation of probability so all the
columns add up to one then it will
always have an eigen an eigenvalue equal
to one and that corresponding
eigenvector is going to be this steady
state distribution if I iterate my
system through here and it doesn't
matter what my initial condition was it
doesn't mean if it doesn't matter if it
was rainy today or cloudy today or nice
today so in fact you should code this up
and you should switch around this
initial condition maybe it's you know
maybe it's cloudy today or maybe it's
nice today or maybe it's rainy today
start from all of those initial
conditions and confirm that very quickly
the steady state probability
distribution converges to this 0.4.2.4
okay that's uh definitely going to
happen
well I should point out um a lot of my
the the majority of these python codes
that I'm running were actually written
modified from my Matlab codes by Dr Alan
Captain aglu so I'm very grateful uh
that he put these these codes together
and he actually made them really really
nice so for example something else we
can do is instead of just watching this
Vector kind of evolve discreetly as a
printout what if I want to save those
States so I can plot them okay what if I
want to save each of these x's in time
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create
a an array that's going to hold all of
these columns and it's going to be
called the weather
and the weather is going to be a numpy
array and we're going to start off by
filling it with zeros size 50 by 3. okay
so this is
um
you know kind of a I think
I'm probably going to want to make it
three
by 50. I think I want to make it 3 by
50.
Okay so we're basically going to have
this this big array the weather and the
weather is going to keep track of what
my X Factor was on day day one day two
day three day four all the way up to
today 50. okay
um
and so at the end of every day when I
have computed X tomorrow what am I going
to do I'm just going to say
um
the weather
at this
um
Keith column the current column the kth
column of this weather array I'm just
going to populate it with X tomorrow
with this
um with the probability of X tomorrow
and so I'll draw a little picture
because I actually think this will this
will help I'm literally going to have
this huge array of the weather size
three by 50 or 51 something like that I
think three by fifty
and every time I step through a day I'm
literally going to plug in you know X1
X2 X3 and so this thing is going to be a
big array of all of my probability
States over all of the days so these are
the states and this is time okay that's
what the weather is let's hope I didn't
create a typo because I'm transposing
Allen's notation here I definitely
messed something up
um I probably
shouldn't have
done this like this
hmm okay so you're going to see me live
debug python here
okay so I figured out the problem uh the
problem if you read the error message
and I just say
uh I do this I get this error
in this line that says the weather you
know this zeroth column of the weather
equals x today it cannot use shape three
comma 1 into shape three so that's
basically telling me that X today is a
three comma one sized array and the
weather is expecting something that's
just shape three
so if I kind of pull out the zeroth
column of X today even though it only
has a single column that will get rid of
the error message
and this thing converges okay so I'm
pretty sure that I could
uh
have
defined this in a better way so that
this didn't happen you can go check out
Alan's code of course all the links are
here and his you know is going to be
cleaner than my version of this but you
know essentially what we've done is we
have taken as the state of the weather
evolves in time we've put those into as
columns into the weather this big array
that has all of those columns as they
evolve in time again remember that
python starts its indexing from zero not
from one Matlab starts it's indexing of
arrays from one python starts its
indexing at zero so if I want the you
know First Column of the weather that is
the zeroth column if I want the First
Column of X today it is the zeroth
column so you got to just be careful
with that
so now I have this data structure the
weather
and let's just see here I'm going to
reinitialize my X today
and rerun all of this and you can see my
system evolving just like before but now
the last thing we can do that's kind of
fun is now we can actually plot uh the
evolution of these states in time so we
can use this plot Dot Plot and remember
we imported
um from matplotlib the plot command so
Pi plot the weather
the weather
and I'm going to include a grid
and we're going to run that
um I probably want to transpose this
thing
there you go okay
and so these are the three states of my
system
um plotted so on the x-axis is time the
y-axis is probability and these are the
three states of my system and so you can
see that the probability very quickly
within like the first five days you know
the the rainy and cloudy probabilities
converge to point zero there's a forty
percent chance and the nice probability
converges to 20 chance so this is kind
of plotting in time how the states of
the system evolve and we could throw up
a legend if we wanted and you know say
uh you know rainy nice cloudy are going
to be these colors you know uh rainy
cloudy nice but this just gives you an
idea that you can plot this thing
okay good
um and again if you're following at home
and you're you have you know the the uh
Jupiter notebook that Alan wrote and you
have this you'll notice that I kind of
uh foolishly diverged from the plan and
I transposed my Vector you know into a
column Vector because that makes more
sense to me but the code is actually a
lot cleaner as Alan realized if you just
use the row Vector so you can kind of
see where my code diverged and where his
code is better okay that's pretty much
uh it for the coding so I'm actually
going to shut this down for now
and so I'm just going to do a super
duper quick recap
um again you can model systems as they
evolve in time uh you can model the
state of your system as a vector and
that Vector could be a you know set of
probabilities of belonging to one of
these states there could be a transition
Matrix a that propagates that state
forward in time uh something I'd like to
point out is that you know this was a
really simple toy model
but you know systems can get really big
really fast so for example you know this
looks like a toy model it's kind of
Make-Believe and cheesy but let's say
you know really quickly I can start
making this pretty sophisticated let's
say I take planet Earth
and I grid this thing up so I have you
know I have every little grid box that
has Square sides of one kilometer let's
say one kilometer by one kilometer
now I can keep track of this state if
it's rainy cloudy or nice at every grid
point on planet Earth and so now the
state of my system is massive it's you
know probably millions or billions of
degrees of freedom because now I have
this probability at every single point
uh on the surface of the Earth okay so
systems can get really really big really
really fast pretty easily and you know
using these very simple ideas you can
start actually building pretty complex
models for how things evolve in time
maybe you know cloudy rainy and nice is
not actually a very good descriptor
maybe what I want to do is I want to
have you know the temperature the
humidity the uh the pressure things like
that maybe I want to have some
um you know how cloudy it is things like
that at every single grid point in space
for planet Earth again you could build a
huge model this huge huge a matrix model
would propagate that system forward in
time okay so I'm gonna this is gonna be
a theme you're gonna see this a lot that
systems can get really big really fast
even these very uh Toy systems you can
start to bring those into a real world
modeling you can model you know like
every square kilometer on the surface of
Earth as a probabilistic weather model
and then it becomes a lot more first off
probably a lot more realistic because
now things depend on their neighbors and
those will affect the probabilities but
they also become a lot bigger
computations and a lot kind of harder
math problems okay uh just a really
intro kind of overview of how you can
model things with matrices and vectors
thank you foreign
[Music]